the invention of the airplane shows the
remarkable rise of American
entrepreneurship and shows America
taking its places of first-rate power in
the world it also answers the question
which is better to promote economic
growth should we have the federal
government subsidize an industry or
should we leave it to private enterprise
in the case of the airplane we decided
to get the federal government involved
and try to jumpstart the invention of
the airplane because we feared the
possibility that the Germans the French
or maybe the British might invent the
airplane ahead of us so we thought we've
got to get there quickly
let's subsidize the best person we have
and see if we can get the airplane
invented we subsidized Samuel Langley
the head of the Smithsonian Institution
to invent an airplane he was a professor
of astronomy he would have written the
leading book on aerodynamics he was head
of the Smithsonian Institution he seemed
like the man for the job the federal
government gave him enough subsidy to
experiment with two flights he did this
in Washington DC in fact he did it right
on the Potomac River
he built a houseboat and his strategy
was to launch his airplane like a
catapult off the houseboat and then
through that launching the engines would
go the airplane would fly and it would
be a success his first experiment the
airplane was launched off the houseboat
went into the air and crashed into the
Potomac River but he had enough money
for one more he tried it again he said
if I fine tune it'll may work next time
he fine-tuned it he launched the second
airplane again it went right into the
Potomac River no flight the Boston
Herald suggested professor Langley ought
to give up airplanes and try his hand at
submarines the New York Times said it is
so complicated we won't see the
invention of the airplane for another 1
million year
the New York Times was off in nine days
after Langley second flight the right
blood brothers invented the airplane
launched the first successful flight
from Kitty Hawk North Carolina and they
did so for almost one minute they were
in air with a mechanized flight for
almost one minute they improved on that
later went for half an hour an hour
they were the inventors of the airplane
two bicycle mechanics from Dayton Ohio
with two thousand dollars of their own
money experimenting with the curvature
of the propeller the curvature of the
wings getting a just right bird like
they succeeded the federal subsidy
failed the invention of the airplane
shows us the remarkable triumph of
American entrepreneurship and how it's
best done through private enterprise
price without federal interference by
the way we've seen this again in the fur
trade in the steamship industry in the
transcontinental railroad industry
private enterprise succeeds when federal
subsidies fail the airplanes indicate
that the failure of Samuel Langley to
invent an airplane with federal money
and the successful Wright brothers with
their own funds inventing the airplane
illustrates the dramatic effect of free
enterprise and what it can accomplish
when the government gets out of the way
you